Nice to meet you.
Nice to see you, Buzzfeed. What's Trending?
What's Trending? Well we've actually been asking
people what their hidden talent is, so do you have one?
Ahh, Flamenco.
I have separate control over my eyeballs.
That's a pretty high bar, what about you Dax?
I'm a... skilled driver...
Do you have a car here he could get into? I could do some doughnuts? Hold on one sec!!
He's a racecar driver. Yeah. He can't prove it right now but you can take my word for it.
I'm actually a very good, like, dancer at weddings? You put on a little Rhianna and
You put on a little Rhianna and if I've had a glass of champagne, I can do some sweet moves.
I do fancy myself a really good ball player...
but maybe people will say something else who plays ball with me.
Yes. I can pick up things with my toes. Yes, really well.
Oh, this is horribly freaky. You really wanna see this?
I did it once in a race, and it made me win, Because all the guys at the starting line were like "OHH!"
It's just, -you know how you crack your knuckles?
I can crack my ankles, toes, knees, hip, neck, back, wrist, elbows, all of it.
I'm jealous, I can't crack all my bones, but I can crack..
But he can crack his hip and that's when I knew it was true love! (laughter)
I can cry like a baby.
We've been asking everyone if they have a hidden talent.
You know, do something funny with your tongue, or maybe you can cross your eyes?
Are we going there? because I don't think...
I'm not gonna talk about it.  Of course I'm not gonna tell you!!!
It's a hidden talent for a reason.
Buzzfeed is so f***** up. You guys are so f***** up.